[Music]
I'm Christie Brinkley and this is how
you make Prosecco step one in making
Prosecco are their grapes you need great
Galera grapes and here our grapes are
the best because we grow next to the
Piave River which leaves these beautiful
white stones in the root ciao Massimo
Massimo ma bene bene grazie amento port
Ando la terre
ala Dadhichi delle pianta predicament a
protege ldg del Fredo Dylan Veronica
starry Rondo so what he's saying is that
he's using the tractor right now to pile
up the soil on the roots to protect them
during the winter so they don't get cold
and that helps think that grapes really
mature and get extra juicy this is the
only region that you can say it is
Prosecco if it's grown here in the
region of Veneto in Treviso it it has to
be grown here otherwise it's not
Prosecco
step two is soft pressing of the grapes
press softly so we only get the best
grape juice step three is the settling
of the Prosecco this is where you have
to wait for the sediment to all gather
[Music]
step four is where it gets spun because
up until step four it's grape juice now
it's going to be Prosecco that's through
the fermentation process in the giant
vats in the cellar
so this fermentation process takes about
ten days and after that we leave it
alone
to relax and this is where the magic
happens
these are our vats where the
fermentation process takes place until
the juice gets in here it's just grape
juice but this is where it becomes
something special through the
fermentation mmm
you know where it gets its gonna say
quoi actually that's French
how do you say that in Italian I'm still
studying and I speak a little bit of
Italian food and shopping and I'm
working on the rest I actually am
studying Italian online right now I
would say epicotyl avec on so no darou
no tutta la vita it's a shame that
vacations don't last the whole life
[Music]
oh you can't pass this up this is great
acoustics when they're empty they're so
much fun but when they're fall they're
even more fun now the next step we're
going to take that relaxed Prosecco and
we're going to move it into the
autoclave this is where the bubbles
happen so this is really cool it's
filtered again it gets in there and it's
like a bubbling cauldron it's very cool
the final step and it's really fun is
the bottling I mean the machines in the
factory are so great to watch inspecting
the bottle
well
I'm out here
come along here
they come to this machine to get walk
over here and they get killed
over here
we put the cork in we have five bars of
pressure which is really great
what the cage on it to protect you from
the court
you see over here at Paige going on
and we now have the bottles coming out
cork and cave siding right I love all of
them
comes out over here
then it's in the Prosecco
zero sugar organic
no guilt
[Music]
very natural so that's how to make
Prosecco yeah and this is how you enjoy
it Cheers et
yes this is the life I could get used to
this
[Music]